cover a couple of things here the origin
story yeah so you're kind of like a
spokesperson for the nrn not official
spokesman OTT official unofficial no
today you are a member of the NRI do
they recognize you do they appreciate
you like how does that work okay so the
way it started I mean I'm gonna start
from the beginning okay all right so I
had a friend of mine a good friend of
mine who called me up one day and was
like do you want to go shooting and I
was like oh because that time I really
wasn't pro-gun and this was about I was
around 23 holding therefore I'm 34 so
this is 10 years ago yeah and I
hesitated a little bit because my
background growing up like I didn't grow
up with guns in house no one in my
family had a gun
and for me the idea the notion of being
a young black male with a gun it's
always I don't saw see exactly through
the lens of you know gang banger drug
dealers so forth and so on
so that's the mindset I had when with
respect to firearms unconsciously right
I didn't even realize it wasn't
conscious of it until I started getting
into this very heavy and realized okay
wow I was thinking like that didn't
realize it and so but at the same time I
told myself why am I afraid of
essentially what is an inanimate object
right so I think to myself I'm like
alright I really don't want to go I'm a
little terrified but you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and do it and so I
remember getting to the range we get to
the range and we walk into the door and
then I hear the door for where the
actual bays are and I hear the
pop-pop-pop go off and I'm like holy
crap this is actually happening and so I
kind of had this nervousness but I'm
with my friend right and so I don't want
my friend to feel like okay you're
acting kind of like a [ __ ] alright hmm
so I kind of kept it to myself you get
to the counter we do all the paperwork
that you know records the paperwork like
Billy phones all that and he has his gun
we get some ammo we go to the lane I
remember was a very last Lane it was a
maybe the range was top gun in Houston
and so we go to a very last range he
gives me kind of like a brief
instruction about how to shoot the gun
how to load it so forth and so on and so
at that point
I remember picking up the gun terrified
not knowing what to expect not knowing
what was gonna happen so I remember
picking it up it was a little Taurus PT
1151 11 millenium in 40 caliber and this
was a subcompact probably not the best
first time shooting - big [ __ ] Sun
well the gun itself was small caliber
example yeah okay exactly so my
experience if anybody who watched that
as a gun person would be like oh this is
not gonna end well
so I remember standing at the bay and
taking the gun and pointing it and
shooting it and I remember just just the
concussive force the explosion with the
gun dancing in my hand and I was like
holy crap that was terrifying then I
shot it again like I like this [ __ ] and
in the weird thing is it not in a way
that most people think the nerdy aspect
of my brain kicked in right I'm like
holy crap like I'm taking this project
down I'm launching it right several feet
and I just because the second shot
allowed me to realize what just happened
I just contained an explosion in my hand
right I'm like if you don't find that
amazing you know a pulse it's amazing
the thing that people are bothered by is
what comes with it and how people use it
mm-hmm
and I think an analogy that's a fair
analogy but people reject is driving
cars and a lot of these [ __ ] psychos
that have been running over people in
the street I mean it just happen again
Berlin yeah what somewhere somewhere in
Germany some guy ran a bunch of people
over then blew his brains out it's it's
an object right it's a thing that you
use and I'm a huge car guy - same as
well yeah yeah I love cars I mean if
someone said we have to ban cars because
people started running people over with
cars they'd be like well okay I think
we're dealing with a whole bunch of
problems and there's there's a bunch of
things that I think we could probably
agree on one of the things we agree on
is all these mass shootings are horrific
absolutely they're terrifying it's it's
an evil terrible thing
that here's another thing no NRA members
are doing that that's one of the things
that's really kind of [ __ ] up about
people getting angry at the NRA yeah
we've never had a mass shooting ever
I like that that I can recall that was
done by an NRA member I looked I tried
to find them I can't find a mass
shooting that was perpetrated by an M RN
R a member and I think it's so the
biggest problem that a lot of gun owners
especially NRA members have is peep the
conversation that's being had is
basically coloring or actually
forgetting the human element behind
those three letters mm-hmm like the NRA
isn't like this demigod that just sits
in a cloud of Olympia and it's just one
big guy that just it's orchestrating
this entire thing
yeah it's you're talking five million
people yeah right like I'm I'm I'm a
member I'm a gun owner right that that's
who I am
along with five million other people who
were that way and then there are a ton
of other people who think they're
honorary members in our and then a ton
of other people who probably don't mind
being in our a members they just haven't
gotten around with doing it and getting
a membership yeah
and the vast majority of those people
and I'm saying that just to be safe
they're good people I think there's
quite a few good people the people that
have perpetrated all these mass
shootings are definitely not good people
the what's wrong with them well I'll
tell you what's not wrong with them guns
it's not guns that are wrong with them
they use the guns to express what's
wrong with them you know and everybody
wants to look at the object which I get
what's easier well it is easier and it's
it's something that everyone is pointing
to like why do you need an ar-15 why do
you need of this well I don't need that
these are good questions why do you need
these things why do I need that [ __ ]
samurai sword over there I don't know
you know it's like what do you need yeah
okay and that's another thing too though
like and I've said it before I think we
are a victim of our own success in this
country right I do think this is the
greatest country in the world but the
problem with that is is this country was
built on an ideological foundation that
I think it's aids in that our ability to
be as great as we are but we live in the
world now where people don't see the
necessity for something that was never
pretty that was never supposed to be
seen through the lens of necessity in
the first place
the Second Amendment doesn't give me a
right it preserves something that
already existed but what happens is we
have a culture of people who don't who
look at the second women as a privilege
not a right they look at it as a
privilege so that's why they say well
why do you need that well why do you
need more than 10 rounds why do you need
this why do you need that and I'm like
first of all we're framing the entire
conversation under need when that's not
what the Second Amendment is about it's
a right that I've already had it's a
natural right that I had the moment that
I stepped foot on this earth as a person
the right to self-defense is universal
yeah and